in terms of the budget what are you
spending the most money on and and where
are you able to kind of cut back a
little bit oh it depends on each
production um a lot a lot of productions
it's special effect some of the
productions or you're spending a lot of
your money on talent the crew ally is
Alec allocates probably between 14 and a
half of your budget yeah depending how
long you're shooting but it's kind of a
fine balance between all the departments
really but usually if it's a special
effects film that will take up the
majority of a large chunk of the money
how do you deal with neighbors that
maybe don't want you to shoot in the
neighborhood or they're super curious
and they want to be part of the
production because i know this is LA but
still everybody's still when they see
that the the trucks and and possible
talent and the camera people go through
a wide variety of attitudes emotions
yeah la is interesting because they
either one complaint and if we're
permitted you know loans were permitted
properly there's nothing they can really
do but get irritated now they can't come
out and say we can't you can't shoot my
put my house in the scene or you can do
this unless you pay me and you know
sometimes we'll just say here's the next
amount of money just to leave us alone
but most for the most part Nellie people
are usually usually pretty chill unless
you're shooting overnight like we were
this neighborhood if we were shooting
overnight we would then have to be very
quiet hours I'm had to be very quiet and
caused you no respect for the neighbors
but it's still challenging when you're
shooting over nights in a neighborhood
because you know people have day jobs
they have to you have to get up early we
shot something last year and we had a
night shoot it was a horror film of
course the girl comes running out of the
house screaming in the side three in the
morning and the cops show up because the
neighbor thought someone was getting my
mugged so that's interesting but people
really really don't bother you that much
um I just did two movies in Utah and
we'd shut a film and we did a Bollywood
film last year in vegas which was
interesting and we shot on the strip and
we gathered a large crowd gathered
around us because we were coming around
from the Bellagio and some other places
and it was interesting because the stars
of the movie and even the
director are huge mega stars in India
and so there was a lot of indian
tourists there for the holiday so they
mean we've had like 50 60 people
watching us and they were like signing
autographs and that was that was that
was pretty cool because shooting in la
no one really cares sure except for
parking I was just wondering in terms of
like parking in the neighborhood I know
because parking in la is an issue yeah
so how do you try to appease the
neighborhood's usually or every four
neighbors upset normally we have parking
lots okay yeah we will find places like
this location will find a locally we
fight like a nice church and instead of
paying a parking lot for the money like
we don't have don't end up donating
money to the church to use their parking
lot oh this is nice so they're very the
very polite and long as Dudley going on
at the church there they're really
really nice about it we actually shot in
a church parking lot two days ago they
never everyone came over and saw this
and I got was this for a little bit and
so we were the you know this kind of a
nice gesture to get back to the church
and shawn versus just renting and you
know paying ridiculous money for a
parking lot is going to overcharge you
you